you know you gentlemen are up there do
you think that women could be the same
as you guys sitting up there saying
things the same way and be accepted in
the same way
no okay and I think that sucks but I've
thought about this a lot like I uh I've
thought about this a crapload is it in
Birchbox I wrote the first check into
that company and I sat in a pitch at in
Starbucks and said yes in 12 minutes
and I got super pumped and like
emotional like in a good way right not
in a cliched [ __ ] like woman white
just like pumped and and I asked I was
like like I couldn't put my finger on it
and I'm like we've got the 16 O's in a
row you're our first yes and I was cool
and I didn't really think much of it it
was the nicest day it was early in the
spring it was the nicest day of the year
four years ago like it was the first
nice day you know that awesome day that
we love so much in New York so I was
like I'm gonna walk home because I was
kind of in Midtown I was going to Upper
East Side and somewhere around like
eight blocks and I was like huh I really
wondered that idea was so obvious I
really wonder if those were two dudes
would they get it like 11 yeses instead
of one and and I'm disproportion you
know you understand and this is not even
close my mom my wife and my firstborn
daughter are my life right I love my bro
and my dad and all this but that is my
world and I you know if God you know
actually don't care but if my daughter
God for willing would want to be a
big-time entrepreneur and CEO I would
want her to dominate the world and I
think that people want to look at the
world through rosy glasses or very
cynical glasses and I think the answer
is always in between do there's a
million women entrepreneurs or
storytellers that are killing it right
we have to recognize that the way the
market consumes people is different
based on if they're a woman if they're
african-american if they're Muslim
American if they're like they're like
just a million how about pretty how
about just being pretty versus not being
as pretty right so like I mean there's a
million variables in play and I think
it's insane I come from so the Soviet
Union right where everything being the
same is the game it's just not real
right and so
puddling doesn't mean that it's worse it
doesn't mean that it's worse at all it
just means that it's different so is it
the same no it's not the same because
everybody's going to consume it
differently and it's not that by the way
it's also not the same for each you're
an african-american woman the way that
you're consuming me is different than
those two Russian guys over there who
have a connection point with me that's
different so like I think this whole
notion of like like is it the same of
course it's not this it's a silly
question I think what's more important
is I'm a big believer betting on your
strengths and I spoke to it earlier
again like I won the lotto completely
white male in America and porn in the
Soviet Union I won triple big I think
you know like I think that I think we
have to understand how things work but
I'll tell you that my mice how about
this Casey and I did a video together
the other day Casey's fanbase hated me
as a net score because I talked over him
during the show cuz I get hyper and this
and that and I went into my own channel
and how to apologize like a 500 people
that came over from Casey's world that
said garyvee [ __ ] you you suck [ __ ]
so you spend less time of what we can't
be and we need to spend more time on
what we can be
you